[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii today we'll talk about
the song that was written in german
although the name is in hebrew kadima
forward thorvalds in german and
it was sung by itzhak as
itzhak was born in 1915 in berlin
germany
he actively participated in jewish
zionist youth groups
and according to his testimony
established
one himself in the interview
given in hebrew itzhak recalls the song
allegedly composed by akiva lewinsky
born in 1918 and died in 2000
a prominent zionist leader here's a
short clip from his testimony
[Music]
is
[Music]
forward is written in the genre of a
solemn probably military march typical
for the anthems
and are the officially sponsored songs
in europe and the soviet union
in the 30s very few of the ideologically
charged songs be the zionists buddhist
or communist
were musically dramatically jewish the
composers
most of them are known to us and the
survivors themselves were part of the
multi-ethnic
multilingual and ultimately cosmopolitan
milieu
in which they grew up
[Applause]
[Music]
yes foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
machine
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when yitzhak refers to this song he
describes it as a
hymn or a hymnan in hebrew that was sung
by members of his german jewish youth
group when they were in
hiding or when they were living as an
underground during the second world war
but he does acknowledge that it was
written earlier during the weimar period
so let's talk a little bit about this
song and what it tells us about german
zionism
during the 1920s and the early 30s well
first of all who wrote it
itzhak and his testimony attributes it
to
akiva levinsky who was an important
figure in the state of israel
during its first four decades he was a
functionary in the jewish agency
he was the director of bankapolium and
he did a lot of other important things
so was he the guy well we do know
that according to his biography he
joined a german jewish youth group
when he was a child when he was nine
evidently
and that it was called kadima well
kadeem is the name of the song
we also know that he wrote music and
poetry as a youth
evidently he wrote poems from early
childhood
he was also a great aficionado of hebrew
from an early age and was committed to
moving to the land of israel
uh but there we have a little bit of a
problem in that he moved
to the land of israel in 1934 when he
was 14 years old
so if he wrote this song and he might
very well have he did it when he was
10 11 12 13 years old now it is a simple
song
so it is possible that he wrote it then
and in the testimony his haqq sings it
in both hebrew and the german and i
wonder if it was written in both
languages
so we can't be 100 sure that lewinsky
wrote it
but i think there's a good chance that
he did it was just a very gifted child
let me say a few words about the song
itself in its broader context it's it's
a very german song
in its cadence and it's music and in its
language
some of it's a bit disturbing like the
reference to ainoya stakes
you know a new and strong breed of
humanity but to be fair
that kind of language was used not only
in the german
world in the 1920s but what's
interesting also is the song doesn't
really say anything specifically about
jews
uh or about judaism or about aliyah
or about arabs israel but there is
something it refers to twice it refers
to honor or era the yudus
or the era of israel that is the jewish
people
and that's not a coincidence the zionist
movement from the very beginning was
very concerned with
with honor and one doesn't have to look
only a german zionism for this
lev pinsker who was from odessa
published a famous pamphlet in 1882
called self-emancipation and it was very
much about honor
but how the jews need to honor
themselves so they can be honored by
the rest of the world honor and respect
were central
in the zionist writings of taylor herzl
so
this is a theme that goes back you know
long before this song
was written and indeed there were german
zionist
hymns of the 19
teens the turn of the century and even
earlier
tater herzl's favorite zionist hymn had
been written in 1885 but it was quite
popular in his own time
and it has language that in some ways is
quite different from the song we're
looking at
but there's a certain commonality i want
to read just a few lines from this poem
it was called
there where the cedar and it begins like
this
there where the slender cedar kisses the
clouds and where the jordan's rapids
flow
there where my father's ashes rest the
earth
has drunk the blood of maccabees
now the reference to maccabees is
important here akiva levinsky
we know that he belonged to a youth
group called kadima which is the name of
this song
well that youth group merged with
another group called sophie
or scouts and it formed a new group
called
young maccabees comparing jews to
maccabees to ancient warriors was found
throughout modern jewish history
but it's particularly powerful in uh
german zionism
and it goes back to 1914 when the
economist and sociologist
franz oppenheimer wrote an essay called
ito annoya
macabe old and new maccabees
now let me now uh talk a little bit
about the background of german zionism
of the 1920s uh on the first tape
of the testimony there's five different
tapes but on the first one itzhak refers
to himself
joining kodima uh when he was a child
now this was an organization that grew
out of a more famous
german jewish youth group called lavis
or blue white that had been founded in
1912.
and it collapsed in 1926 and internal
politics and
youth groups and often sort of came and
went in weimar germany
but what happened over time first in
blauvis and then kodima
is that the movement's focus changed
like the german youth movement as a
whole in the earlier 20th century the
emphasis was on individual cultivation
personal experience with nature long
rambles through the forests
music and so forth in germany and among
german jewish youth as well
as we get further into the 1920s and the
early 30s
the youth movements become more
nationalistic and for the jewish youth
movements a greater emphasis
not just on zionism but on aliyah on
immigration to eretz israel
and preparation for life in
the land of israel as a laborer
particularly on ikebutz
kadima was part of a whole umbrella
group of
german jewish youth groups that had
about 2 000 young people in all
and i just want to read you a sentence
from the founding statement of this
umbrella organization
because it really gives you a sense of
what german youth groups
german jewish youth groups were all
about when you get into the later
twenties
we firmly believe that in palestine the
cornerstone for a new society is being
laid
we cannot do a thing here except to
prepare ourselves
to become worthy helpers of the
palestinian workers
and to teach the german jewish youth the
ideal of a new and dignified life in
eretz israel
note the emphasis not only on labor but
also on dignity which gets us back to
honor that i talked about earlier now
how we judge the seriousness of these
statements really depends on
perspective there were um
about 2 000 german jewish youth in these
organizations
uh hundreds of them did wind up moving
to eretz israel in the 1920s
about 2 000 german jews and all moved
to eretz israel that might not sound
like many
but there were 20 000 german jews uh in
the syrian easter shift
line the the german zionist organization
and that's actually quite a lot
when we think about the jewish
population of germany being about half a
million
in the united states which had eight
times as many jews more than four
million jews
there were about 60 000 jews total
in the american zionist organizations so
you know three times as many as in
germany but the community was eight
times larger
and also the american community was
about
13 000 members of the american zionist
organization and the rest were in
hadassah the women's zionist
organizations it was split
immigration to the land of israel was
low so actually german zionism was much
more committed to errors israel
than um american zionism and german
zionism was more
popular in germany than american zionism
was in the united states
and that might be counterintuitive but i
think it's important to keep that in
mind
the german jewish world that gave birth
to this song then was one where zionism
was pretty prevalent
uh not dominant prevalent and within
zionism there was a serious commitment
to immigration even if not
um all the time realized in principle
the fact that the song itself doesn't
refer to the land of israel is a bit of
a red herring
it may have been written by again a very
young man still a boy
whose own thinking was in the process of
formation
or perhaps if it was written by someone
else it was written at a time when the
youth movement was undergoing
transformations and debates about how
important erotism would be to it
all this to say that we can learn an
awful lot from a little song
[Music]
bye